hello and welcome i'm james murphy from
emcoding.io
where i offer nine week weekend
programming courses
today brownie in motion
[Music]
if you're watching this video you've
probably heard of brownian motion before
but the purpose of this video is not so
much to tell you what brownie emotion is
but rather to give you a way to simulate
it so that you can play with it yourself
surprisingly simulating brownie emotion
is actually not that difficult
i've already imported numpy for doing
some of the
math operations and numpy for plotting
the first thing that i'm going to do
is to find the number of time steps that
i want to use
and my time horizon so this means that
i'm going to be simulating brownian
motion from time 0
to time 1 and i'm going to do so using
10
000 sample points next we'll use
numpy.linspace to make the set of times
that we're going to use
so linspace takes the initial time
the final time and the number of sample
points
just for your benefit let's go ahead and
print out times with a small number of
time steps so you can see what it's
doing
you can see it's just going in uniform
increments
zero up until one continuing on i think
the next thing that we're going to need
is what is the time step that is between
each of those times so we'll just take
times of one
minus times of zero the next thing that
we need to figure out is
how do we actually get values of the
brownian motion
well almost the characterizing property
of brownian motion is its independent
normally distributed increments what
that means is that if i have brownian
motion at some time t2
and i subtract brownian motion at some
time t1
well then this is a random variable and
it's
normally distributed with
mean zero and
variance t2 minus
t1 so instead of trying to find a single
formula
for the browning motion i'll just
generate
all of these normally distributed
increments and then add them up
so let's make db meaning the increments
of brownian motion the differences
between uh the values of the brownian
motion
that will be a
numpy random normal and
let's give it a
shape or size which is equal to
we're going to need the number of time
steps minus 1
because the first one is always going to
be zero brownian motion starts at zero
then we need n minus one for the rest of
time steps
so by default this is going to give me
mean
zero variance one and what i need
is variance dt
because we're looking at increments of
the brownian motion which are in
times in this array all of those times
consecutive times in that array
are separated by a distance of dt
from each other so in order to get a
variance of dt i'll need to multiply by
the square root of dt
so let's just do that num pi square root
of dt times that so db now
is an array of differences
of values of brownian motion we still
haven't constructed
any of the values yet just their
differences to get the actual values of
browning emotion
we'll need to start with its value at
zero and then
cumulatively add up the differences so
branding motion starts at zero so let's
just use
numpy dot zeros to create the array
and it takes a shape parameter and
we're just gonna have one zero for now
later on we're going to be generalizing
to
simulating multiple browning motions or
equivalently
a single multi-dimensional browning
motion
so if you don't understand why we're
choosing to make this zero an array
instead of just a scalar
just keep that in mind that we're going
to be generalizing in a little bit to
get the actual values of the brownian
motion
we just need to concatenate the initial
value
with the cumulative sum of the
increments so
i'll take these things to be
concatenated let's take b
0 and the cumulative sum
of the increments
and then we can go ahead and just plot
it so we'll plot that
x values are the times and the y values
are the brownian motion and then we'll
show the plot
so if we did everything correctly then
we should see a plot of brownian motion
all right that looks pretty good to me
one thing that i do want to test
is i just want to make sure that
if we used less time points that we're
still getting the right thing
so i do see that it starts at zero and
it's going around
the value minus one of course it's
random but
the values that you get for brownian
motion shouldn't depend on the number of
sample points
but only on the time horizon
so if i go out to t equals one it
shouldn't matter
if i take 10 000 sample points i should
still have something which is around the
range
plus or minus one and you can see
even though it's a totally different
sample path different number of sample
points
we do end up around one now of course
it's possible that that doesn't happen
but it's just the most likely thing is
to be in that range
minus one to one if you did this
experiment and you found that when you
increase the number of sample points
that the value of your brownian motion
was
increasing then you probably would have
messed up the scaling so for instance if
i delete this
proper scaling by square root of t and
then
run the simulation again so here you can
see
that by time one uh we're getting values
that are up at
like 80 and down to minus 50
almost minus 60. so if you see that
that should be your clue that brownie
motion doesn't move that
much in that amount of time so if that
happens check your scaling
i'll go ahead and put the proper scaling
back in there okay so that's
one brownie in motion what if we want to
increase the number of samples
let's introduce a new parameter d which
is the
number of brownian motions that we're
going to simulate
all at once so for now let's just have
say five brownian motions
so how can we modify this now our times
are not going to change because
um they're all living on the same time
axis
since our times didn't change our dt
doesn't change either
the first thing that actually changes is
going to be the increments
so instead of being normally distributed
with this size now we need to just add
in
a d here the first coordinate is going
to be our time coordinate
and the second coordinate is going to be
our either
space coordinate if you're thinking of
it as a multi-dimensional browning
motion
or the index of the brownian motion if
you're thinking about it
as a bunch of independent
one-dimensional brownian motions
which is how it will be drawn when we
plot it of course now the initial value
of the brownian motion
is going to be 1 by d because there are
d components of it now oh and by the way
if you wanted to consider a brownian
motion that's not started at 0
this is exactly where you would change
it you just put in the numbers that you
want there and then you'll get
samples of your brownian motion started
at that place
there are two things that we need to
change on this line namely
now that our db has
more than one dimension to it we need to
specify when we do the cumulative sum
and when we do the concatenation what
axis we're doing that over
so i know that i want to sum in time
not in space so i want to sum at the
zero
axis not the one axis so let's change
the
cumulative sum to axis equals zero
and let's change the concatenation axis
to axis equals
zero again that's because i again
want to concatenate b0 on as
the first time step not as a spatial
dimension
then we can go ahead and plot it again
so there you have it it looks like we
have
a good five samples of brownian motion
going
just for fun let's bump up the number of
browning emotions and see what it looks
like when we do a hundred
if you've never seen a picture like this
i would encourage you to sit and stare
at it for a while
it's a little bit mesmerizing
even though our brownian motion was made
up of
totally independent increments
every single one was just randomly
generated
we're starting to see some structure
here even with a hundred sample paths
there's a clear shape that's emerging
where the brownian motion really tends
to not go
outside of that shape let me bump it up
to a thousand here just so we can get a
little bit better picture of that shape
now we see a very defined shape with
just
a few outliers out of a thousand samples
we have almost a parabolic shape
that's emerging if you're interested in
learning about this property it's
actually a very well known fact
you should look up what's called the law
of the iterated logarithm
for brownian motion it tells you that
brownian motion really tends not to
exceed
about square root of 2t and
from the name you can guess that there's
a logarithm or 2 hiding in there
but that's not for this video this just
shows that
by simulating you can gain a lot of
insight into the statistical properties
of a kind of random process like
brownian motion
the last thing that i wanted to show you
is another
key insight that you can see just by
simulating like this
another characteristic factor of
brownian motion it has so many
interesting properties but
one of them is its quadratic variation
now the quadratic variation isn't
something that you would probably come
up
in a video just about browning in motion
it's more of
something that you can look at for a
general stochastic process
and it just turns out to have a very
interesting formula
when you put in brownian motion
the quadratic variation is not a whole
lot more than what it sounds like
basically we're just going to take
differences of the brownian motion
square them and add them so let's take
the numpy
difference of the brownian motion
along the axis zero because remember
zero was for time
and to preserve the original dimensions
of the brownian motion i'll just go
ahead and prepend
zero because the quadratic variation
is something that's defined just like
browning motion to start at zero
then i'll take those differences and
raise them to the power two
then i will again use the cumulative sum
function
so that i can graph them and again we'll
do this along
x 0 that's the time axis and then i will
just return it
if you didn't quite follow the formulas
and dimensions that went into this
just consider the case where d equals
one then all the axis stuff disappears
and what you end up having is basically
look at the
differences of the brownie motion take
them to the power two
and add them up so now instead of
plotting
b let's plot the quadratic variation of
b
huh that's weird
when you see this picture you might
think that i've done something wrong
just to be sure that i haven't
accidentally messed up the brownie in
motion somehow
let's go ahead and plot again just throw
that original plot of b back in
so you can see the brownian motion is
still
wiggling all over the place it has all
of the same properties that we were
talking about before
but yet this quadratic variation looks
like just a line
and indeed that is the case the property
that i was alluding to earlier is that
the quadratic variation of brownian
motion
is just t at time t
brownian motion has had exactly
t quadratic variation that's why this
looks like the line y equals x
so even though we have the full force of
all the randomness of browning motion
going on here
we find that when we look at squares of
differences
and add them up all of these different
sample paths
look like this just a line so that's
another key property of browning motion
and it's really cool that we can
actually see it even just with our you
know finite simulation
that's all i have for today on brownie
in motion let me know if you want to see
more on this topic and as always if you
liked the video don't forget to like
comment and subscribe thanks see you
next time
you